you're gay great fine no problem we
totally have no issues with that at all
if you follow the podcast you know my
history what i you know i i'm very
comfortable with that but i don't see
people on twitter in their profile
saying part of the straight community
you know you don't see improv you don't
know what i'm saying like it's like the
reason that there's bet right because
black people needed a voice whenever
that started in the 70s now if you had
wet white entertainment television now
we get a problem it's just and i agree
with that i don't think there should be
a but entertainers have dominated uh
media for whatever but i think that is
more
part of the
division that's happening that that that
feeds into it now don't get me wrong i
think there's there's i'm all about
anybody that's very proud to be
mexican proud to be guatemalan proud
like ricky's michoacan
i love people that are proud of their
heritage proud to be
you know middle eastern jewish whatever
you are i have a lot of respect for that
i like i think heritage and traditions
powerful but from the standpoint of
because i am this i'm more important
than you i'm more i need to be heard
more than you and you know trying to
convert the way it's being done today
i'm not with it that that data itself
can should concern every single parent
in america that data that bill maher
showed if you've not seen it that data
that bill mills millshore showed
everybody who's a parent ought to be
concerned about that data today let me
give you two quick points um what
happens is people who are marginalized
let's what let's say it's the black
community or the gay community or the
jewish community they start off saying
hey we need a voice like we're getting
drowned out here we're being
marginalized or being discriminated
against like my dad who grew up in
detroit would tell me
when he grew up in detroit they'd used
to say signs no blacks no jews no dogs
okay
straight up that's what he grew up with
in the 50s all right so you develop a
voice but then what happens is
once your voice comes becomes a little
bit louder let's say it's the lgbtq
community let's say it's the bet
community now you become part of the
mainstream and now the mainstream says
all right well
i don't i'm not lgbt what just happened
here but because you start off as a
small voice
and you become part of the mainstream
pop culture now you're you're in the
ecosystem of pop culture this the second
part because there's someone's probably
watching it's like what does catalina
and aoc
and political divisions have to do with
lgbt
and the
common thread there is whether it's
nature versus nurture and to the bill
mars point is that what essentially is
happening is now the debate is over this
is no longer part of nature it's now
being part of nurture
whereas one percent of people baby
boomers were gay and then two percent of
or four percent of gen x um and then
millennials now it's five percent gen z
is now it's ten percent twenty percent
it's like hold on clearly an
indoctrination is happening and that's
essentially the common thread there my
issue is that it's being pushed by these
millennial young teachers at such a
young age and parents don't even have a
voice sometimes but also the fact that
it's influencing legislation if you have
0.01 of the population or the statistic
on untransgenders for example and then
now people are forced to have one
bathroom or a transgender bathroom it is
influencing legislation on such a mass
scale because it's being pushed by the
far left so much that that does impact
the rest of the country why are these
small voices dominating policy you can't
even get policies passed for for
veteran health care that quickly but you
can get transgender bathrooms pushed on
a federal level in some cases that's
ridiculous to me so how do we solve it
so what's the solution so if you're if
you're saying what you're saying what is
the solution parents need to have a
voice at the school level they need to
stop this at that level and say teachers
your job is to teach my child math
social studies gym whatever and to take
your political culture war
opinions out of the classroom and then
parents need to have
need to educate their kids on what's
going on in a thoughtful way
so that they're not being it's part of
the culture now
so okay so parents uh run for school
board run for school board but okay so
say you do that what else is the
solution though tom what is there really
so i guess this is a question i'm trying
to ask is there really a solution or is
it in too deep
have they already
uh gotten so deep into universities and
school systems that to be able to shift
this is going to take a decade or two
and if you do how do you do it
well this is exactly the problem you
know you have um
the far left that is influencing the
kids because they want to
tell the kids
what to think they do not want the
children to be guided culturally by the
parents
they feel that they should guide the
children culturally and they feel that
people call it grooming people call it
whatever you want
that's the issue and she's right but
this is good this is a decade-long fight
because it took a while to get here
and people are waking up to it what
happens is
mark twain said the fog comes in on
little cat feet you don't really hear it
but the fog comes in
and what has happened here over the last
20 years there has been a steady march
toward the schools bringing in content
that is increasingly left culture at the
public school level
that's where they're driving it
in dallas two of the biggest private
schools that you would say they are
probably
a tick conservative they're not
religious schools but both of them have
what's called the safe room where you
can go in and have a discussion about
being gay experimenting
gender confusion which they don't call
it confusion
and they will not tell your parents
will not tell your parents so your child
like this young woman this 13 year old
you were talking about confused for a
year could be sitting there constantly
having these conversations in a safe
room and they don't tell the parents so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]